look as the first-time entrepreneur CEO
there's gonna be many different
situations you're gonna face and
sometimes you're gonna be tempted to
make a decision that's gonna be tough
for you so today I'm gonna share with
you ten situations every entrepreneur
will face so the first one's very simple
every entrepreneur that starts a
business typically you have somebody
that's working with you that's either a
relative or a friend so now when you
work with a relative and a friend at
first everything's exciting oh my gosh
we're gonna go something big together
we're gonna go out there and do this and
we're gonna go out there and do that and
all of a sudden the personalities can
work together in one of the situations
you're gonna face it's having to fire a
friend or a relative and it's very very
hard to do for most first-time
entrepreneurs because it's friendship
but in reality when you're running a
business the priority of a business it's
to stay in business even if it means
having to fire a relative or a best
friend in the world because if the
business goes out of business everybody
else is affected this next one is very
interesting because most people when you
start a business you kind of go oh my
gosh we're gonna go out then we're gonna
do this I'm gonna build this business
we're gonna start regional then we're
gonna go national then we're going to go
international we'll be global be so big
right and you think you're fully in you
think you're fully in right I've put
$100,000 into it I put $50,000 into it I
put a half a million dollars into it I
put my life savings into it I'm all-in
but there's still another face of all in
face of all in there you're gonna face
and when you get there that's when as
hard as you tap except the beginning
anybody that starts a business they
don't really think about how tough this
business is gonna be you typically at
first think it's a lot easier then it's
really going to be you're like oh my
gosh this is gonna be great all our
dreams are gonna become a reality then
you realize the real challenge of
becoming an entrepreneur and in that
moment is when you realize if you're 100
percent in or not because it's it's not
gonna be an easy moment it's gonna be a
very very tough moment where almost
everything you look at doesn't make
sense nothing makes sense for you to
continue on paper logically
thing makes sense why you could make it
or why you ought to continue but it's in
that moment where you find out if you're
a person that's all in or everybody
around you realizes slowly but surely
you're finding your way out of being an
entrepreneur back to being an employee
and you will know when you get in that
moment because that moment no one's
gonna know except for one person and
that's you all right so this next one's
tough because when you typically make
the transition of being an employee to
want it to be an entrepreneur you still
have a lot of friends that are employees
who you want to associate yourself with
but you're now an entrepreneur an
entrepreneur it's almost like going from
you know babysitting someone's baby to
now you have a baby and when you have a
newborn baby
you can't go watch movies you can't go
through a lot of things when you have a
newborn baby because that newborn baby
needs to be fed diapers needs to be
changed they need attention they're
crying they're waking up three four
times to go out tonight and that's gonna
last a year and a half two years three
years that's the startup phase so when
you're married with kids trying to hang
out with friends that are single with no
kids going to nightclubs that's gonna
clash and these guys gonna say I thought
we were friends you know just like your
buddies that have regular jobs are gonna
say wait a minute we still hang out
together it seems like everything about
your life is now your business what
happened to this guy all you care about
is money and you're not gonna have an
answer for them at first but now that
you watch the video now you know in
order to make the business work for a
period you have to be all-in and this
means most likely you may have to cut
some of your hobbies that you were doing
before you won't be able to do right now
because if you don't stay focused on the
business this thing is gonna go out of
business and you're eventually gonna
find yourself on this side so the
tipping point is gonna be at one point
we're gonna have a make a decision and
say no to some of your friends that
don't understand what it is to be an
entrepreneur so this next one's a little
bit confusing because when you start the
business you're gonna have certain
competitors that are supportive of you
and they're kind of like Oh John listen
you're gonna get it go get them it's
gonna be all great and these competitors
who were once supportive now become your
enemies and they don't like you anymore
they become haters they start talking
behind your back so what does that
really mean this guy used to tell me
he's supporting my decision why is he
now all upset with me here's why the
reality of it is when he used to support
you when you were small
he knew
thought you were gonna get bigger he
never thought you were gonna make it
because if he knew you were gonna get
bigger and you were gonna compete
against them he would have never liked
you in the first place and he would have
never allowed you to compete with them
because that was never the intention the
intention was you're always gonna stay
small and you're never gonna take a
market share but the bigger you get and
you take some market share away from
certain people those competitors that
were supportive are officially haters of
yours so this next one is the
contradiction of what I just said I'm
explain to why this is a contradiction
of what I just said so remember those
same competitors that used to support
you then you started getting big now
they don't like and they hate you and
then if you experience this next part
which is magical is you get so big that
those competitors that ended up hating
you end up loving you and becoming
supportive of you because you're no
longer in the same league you're in a
different league they'll call you and
now they are supportive they'll call you
because there's now a level of
admiration but to get to this level you
have to go to the level of hate and that
hate may last a few years it may be five
ten years until they end up saying you
know what you got just give it up to
this guy this guy's just better than us
and you know what I love and respect
this guy much love to you let me just
call you hey man you know I used to hate
on you I should say a lot of bad things
about you but I love you and I love what
you doing I've got to give you respect
you're just kicking everybody's butt
more you know more love to you keep at
it so proud of you keep at it whatever I
can do to help you out I'm cheering you
on I hate the fact that you beat me but
guess what we now know you're better
than us and whatever we're doing that
happens when that happens that's an
incredible feeling but it takes about a
decade for that to happen to you all
right so this next one is interesting
because you'll be building your business
and at first when you're not taking a
lot of money because your investment
back into your business you'll get to a
point where you can now take the profits
out and sometimes while you're going and
you want to take the profits out if you
take too much profits out you can no
longer put back into the business to
grow whether its marketing hiring
support growth expansion and sometimes
you will be tempted
they'll come a time where you go to your
checking account your business check in
here and say oh my gosh we have some
money in this checking account I am
tempted to take two million off the
table I am tempted to take a million
dollars off the table whatever size of
the business you got I'm tempted to take
10 million dollars
the table in that moment sometimes if
you're going to take in the profits out
versus putting back into the business
sometimes you jeopardize long-term
valuation of building a really powerful
business and you're tempted over taking
short-term profits out and you will be
tempted to do that this doesn't mean you
don't set a little bit of money aside to
save yourself you know cities safer and
set aside for yourself on your family
and savings but if you go into this mode
of concept taking profits that
eventually long-term valuation and
potentially the company keeps going
lower and lower and lower so maybe that
is what you wanted and maybe you just
want to take the profits you don't care
about long term valuation but if you do
care about this you cannot be tempted to
take the short term profit side because
long term radiation goes down this next
one's also tough for first-time
entrepreneurs because when you become an
entrepreneur there's gonna come a time
where you have to say no to your family
when you used to say yes to meaning may
be used to say yes we can go out there
and buy this and we can go out and do
this and now money's a little bit
tighter because you're running a
business that money's now being invested
into the business and you're a wife or
your husband or your spouse or your kids
or partner or parents or whoever it is
they were accustomed to the you saying
yes to a lot of the expenditure you had
before you can't right now because for
good your two-year three-year period
you've got to stay tight and that
money's got to get back into the
business it creates friction sometimes
because if your spouse doesn't really
know about the commitments you made and
the sacrifices that come with it if
they're not aware of it and you don't
have the conversation with them there's
gonna be some friction between the two
of you you're gonna have that
conversation so when instead of getting
to the point of having that conversation
just make sure you talk about it upfront
and everyone knows we're gonna have to
be tied in certain areas because daddy
or mommy have chosen to start a business
for themselves and there's gonna be a
little bit of period where we may not
have money to do the things that we used
to do that trip that this and that we
have to be a little bit tighter because
we're going for the long term victory so
so we've talked a lot about business
family all this other stuff one of the
things that could happen is when you
build your business you will face a
situation where departments go against
each other maybe sales is going to go
against support or investors don't like
the board or you don't like the board
port doesn't like you you know your
engineers don't get along with sales
marketing doesn't yelling with sales
there's gonna be some kind of a division
that happens on the team
because typically when a company's being
ran if you don't do it properly from the
top every department has to know that
their role is very important every
department has to know that their role
is very important and at the same time
every department also has to know who is
more important meaning for instance
we'll have a meeting here and say a home
office kind of starts being a little bit
too tough on sales I'll sit down I'll
say listen I just wanna remind everybody
without sales this company doesn't exist
matter ourselves no company exists
sometimes just like the government of a
country starts thinking they're more
important than the job creators and the
entrepreneurs sometimes corporate
forgets the fact that the creative
people or the sales people are really
the ones that are holding the company
together and this is a support team
there's gotta be a respect here but
there's got to be an admiration from
here to know that these guys are working
24/7 these guys may be working 8-10
hours a day five days a week but they're
working six seven days to be going all
over the place away from their family to
sell there has to be an expectation of
what is the priority but they're all
fast it has to be a very clear
understanding from everybody that every
single job done by every single person
it's critical to the growth of the
company if that conversations not had
then you're gonna have some friction
amongst different teams and if there's
division then bad things can happen to
your business so you as a leader gotta
make sure you always bring everybody
together everybody has perspective to
understand what roles they play
everybody gets properly recognized
encouraged praised so then from there
they're working as a team like they once
used to you know this next one is tricky
because when you're building your
business and all of a sudden you have a
lot of leverage and you have the ability
to do certain things people are gonna
bring opportunities to you that are kind
of like shortcuts and I remember this
happened to us with the business
throughout my career hey if you do this
no one's gonna know you'll make an
additional million dollars on the set if
you do this no one will know you'll make
an additional two million dollars on the
side or half a million dollars on the
side and when you're only making a two
million dollar of your income and
somebody says you're gonna make an
additional two million dollar your
income or million dollar income that's a
lot of money that's not a little - a lot
of money when you kind of are we in
tempted by it so meaning if the real
idea of the business you're building
long term is to truly build a business
that grows and becomes a legacy company
you can't you can't fall for the
shortcuts your character will be
that many many many times now I'm not
talking about like additional sources of
income to generate for the business
that's the right way of doing it but I
am talking about you're gonna get
certain offers and opportunities that
are gonna hurt your core your core
fundamental philosophy of how the
business was built if you start trying
to go for all the shortcuts this is
gonna break and a lot of times when
business people are entrepreneurs are
building a business they start looking
so much this way that they forget the
core that's holding it all together so
while they're doing this this collapses
them once this collapse you don't have
time to do this because you're trying to
do this and it's too late already
you're lost it already you got to make
sure you get this speaker and every once
in a while you're looking for
opportunities that's gonna help this
continues to get bigger not just another
shortcut are you gonna have out there
you will face it when you do just make
sure you make the right decision because
it's gonna hurt your long-term if you
don't listen last ones last one
something no one will know when you're
facing this nobody's gonna know you're
gonna be facing this because it's all in
here when you go through this and here's
what it is there will come a time where
you're still in a business mode but your
business is making money you're growing
and you are no longer the same
hard-charging leader with high standards
and expectations or wanting to deliver
the right product and all this stuff
because now you're going to nice dinners
and you got money in the bank and maybe
driving a nice car live in a nice house
and you're no longer stressed like when
you used to be feeling like oh my gosh
we're gonna run out of money that that
idea of the survival mode that's gone
and you get casual and when you get
casually become casual with all the
departments salespeople competitors
everybody and then phone your car this
happens unboxing this happens I'm
fighting this happens and sports this
happens in every single thing and if it
happens in a business world the way you
typically get knocked out is somebody
internally decides to turn against you
or an external competitor says I'm gonna
go out and get this guy because he's
getting softer or a new competitors
coming up if you get too soft or your
habits of being casual gets rubbed off
to your management team and your c-suite
executives then they pass it to their
directors the directors pass it to their
employees now everybody's leaving on
fridays early and you kind of like oh
we're gonna take three days off four
days are five days up
day off everything becomes a little too
comfortable and when that happens you
already know what happens when that
happens in wars when that happens in
sports when that happens on teams when
that happens in businesses somebody
hungrier than you with bigger vision
higher standards and expectations is
gonna come and put you out of business
because that's how business works the
moment somebody gets soft another person
with a clear vision higher standard will
attract the right talent and they
essentially will come out and say your
towns been had five ten fifteen years
now it's our turn please your markets
yours coming to us you may not go out of
business but you may lose your market
share from eight percent to four percent
to two percent that is a form of going
out of business because you're getting
smaller and smaller so that is why it's
critical to maintain high standards and
expectation that is the only way
continuously to grow year after year
after year after year after year even
when bad market temps come up so don't
be tempted to lower the standards
because you will be when you start
making good money so look if you're
watching this video you're an employee
about to become an entrepreneur or
you're an ounce you're putting on your
first year I got two videos I want you
to watch one of them is 10 things to do
before you become an entrepreneur click
on it if this applies to you the other
one is 12 mistakes I made as an
entrepreneur my first year I think this
one's got one and a half million views
click on whichever one applies to you
and if you haven't subscribe to the
channel do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye bye
you
[Music]